- But isn't it true that Queen
Latifah kind of inspired you
to start recording?
- Well, Queen Latifah,
at a club called Nell's,
this was actually goes further back.
- Oh, wow.
- Is like when I was a bouncer in New York
anytime I saw a musician, I said,
"I could rap, I have raps,
I have flow, I have bars."
And she said, "Do something."
And I did this kind of guttural sound
that would later become Groot.
And she said, "Can you carry
that through a whole song?"
Later in life, about six years ago,
I was at an Oscar party and she said,
"I would buy a CD of you mumbling."
- Oh my gosh.
And by the way, you mentioned
it, so I'll talk about it.
Groot's my favorite character.
(Vin Diesel applauding)
And it's my mother and I's,
we separately found this out.
'Cause I was like, she had a little Groot
and I was like, "Is that your fave,
"that's my favorite one."
- [Vin Diesel] That's awesome.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you're
out favorite, just saying.
- Oh thank you.
- [Kelly] I'm a huge fan of
"Guardians of the Galaxy"
You win.
- Oh, thank you.